- Austin elevators hi everyone welcome
back to resident evil I'm Mike McCarty
or Tom turkey gobble gobble malaria if
you're in the u.s. happy Thanksgiving
weekend if you're outside the u.s. happy
weekend period as always thanks for
stopping by we'll get right into it
recording this on Wednesday right which
one is it I did a game pip oh we went
back to it okay we had to because this
one is 4 by 3 so I have to put it like a
bad hair day smell but if you hate the
me too cuz its rainy but that rains
awesome because it's been smoky and has
hazardous air quality to last this is
where we stopped right like I'm not not
yes I remember Chris and Jessica
discovered they were on a different oh
[ __ ] Sorry Sorry
remember they discovered they're on a
different tanker we're on the Queen
Zenobia they're on the Queen someone's
barest bye what just happened
you wasted a grenade during that extra
life stream - God does that ring a bell
Kristen just got discovering they were
searching the wrong tanker yes it does
I hold on I really should figure out
what we're doing oh my god did I just
take a he'll know why I hit that I'm
trying to like remember what button
brings up my inventory and I'm not doing
bad nothin great job it's right there
just like our one in l1 to get your map
and oh yeah yeah I've like lost my brain
here didn't I go like severely out of
the way oh that was Chris but you're on
the right way right now okay so gonna
take this tunnel going back to the main
hall all right so we're doing the right
thing mm-hmm a favor by raphy shot and
stuff is gonna make sure this this is
the same ps4 Pro we're using with the
audio it's weird last time that sounds
fine I think it's hard to tell
bear with me I'm gonna turn the gameplay
up oh hold on a second isn't this the
thing that almost killed me a lot of
time so we didn't do this before I don't
remember if you did it as maybe remember
yeah you're gonna
shuto up I [ __ ] up
what do I do
you're gonna die why didn't you shoot it
I thought I did you know what I'm fine
with this I had a really bad beginning
I'm just I thought we did this vision oh
did we do it at the end of last episode
for funsies
how would happen possibly yeah or Chris
you did it as Chris again like the
tankards marry each other I can't
remember I can look it up actually I'll
look up comments anyway while we're here
okay if you're not in the knievel
discord that's pretty active discord
well walk well you too come on there we
go sorry people like Nathan Shepherd and
well Nathan Shepherd largely moderate
sit and stuff we remember when I showed
your dance video yes I love like I love
how that was all a cover for me to waltz
to the bar god that was so funny
and I Nick margarita our friend made an
appearance got you you little [ __ ] I
can hear him now remember how we
couldn't hear him before I think the
audio state we just plugged we that PC
is also in that stuff but yes well it's
fixed
hey look it's mine mmm do a wine tasting
I don't think people know what you're
referencing right now you wanna do the
wine thief oh if it's Saturday if you
feel like watching a fun Thanksgiving
break video Lucy James
it's her first Thanksgiving but we
Ubisoft sent like six of these
Assassin's Creed themed wines to us and
we did a tasting and then we ranked the
Assassin's Creed games based on their
wines so it's very very educated and
like in no way [ __ ] so go watch that
song you sports youtube channel oh my
god what a mean thing to say they're
ugly bodies are not of this world their
stench like rotting organs and their
screams like echoes from Hell itself
they're bloated blisters on the walls
are their eggs they can regenerate from
them don't think that I've abandoned you
I
it for my family you totally did do that
last time but then it might we might
just miss the autosave look you're
climbing the ladder at the end of last
episode so you're like essentially where
you are yeah music you're literally no
you're literally right here this like
okay and then we cut back to this okay
because I didn't save it we thought it
autosave I guess it didn't you're right
okay okay so what items let's see
[Music]
do we want ya remember you have a quick
turn as well
do we want these items
I like these items
[Music]
this one doesn't have any how do I
upgrade my guns you do it at that at
this box right yeah it's just like don't
understand what I'm doing
Oh square got it
I should add a couple things to this guy
if we're gonna use it some dommage
what's 20% damn we don't like burst
what's days what's done pretty nice mmm
what that seems like I don't know if
that combo is great if you're gonna go
for damage I don't know if you also want
stun okay so I might be better use on
something else like a shotgun okay well
I guess you already have damage to in
the shotgun - uh well actually no I'm
sorry so the shotgun already has a lot
of days I think so it's up to you
wherever you put it maybe on the handgun
or something I don't know I don't know
it depends on your philosophy when
you're upgrading stuff I'm one of those
people who likes to bolster the
weaknesses of like weapons but other
people like to emphasize the
pre-existing strength I'm gonna
emphasize the pre-existing strength okay
I just spit on you just don't tell me I
wouldn't have known if you didn't say
anything with anybody at home oh my god
froze no you did this has Chris you've
died a few times in this room yes well
the other tanker alright just making
sure okay so we're just going straight
okay so I want to go towards this door
mm-hmm I can do that
didn't I already read this again that
was on a different tanker unless you're
talking about the end of last episode I
just can't remember anymore okay why are
you doing this
I 107 grams remember that okay
Diego pooch said I've left a lot of the
show but I don't think I've ever laughed
more than when Mary took off her
invisaligns sorry Mary but I think we
all looked and laughed at least a little
I think I did dramatically take them out
like it's not like it's painful
it's just that it's they stick to cuz
they're molded to your teeth so when I
take them out keep updating them every
so often so they it feels like I'm
taking out my [ __ ] teeth you know
what I mean like it doesn't feel great
but it doesn't hurt Charlie Kelly I was
being a bit dramatic
Ava Cassandra a longtime viewer said
fresh off the five-hour episode and just
finished this one and uh revelations is
so fun a story inheritance can be goofy
but I'm having a way better time just
watching this one Xander crease also
longtime viewer said tip the yellow dot
on the bottom right of the scanner tells
you there's an item nearby and that's
why we missed a lot of ammo last time I
haven't used my scanner at all this way
go back and use doing the casino there's
probably something sort of bad oh my god
what better never burp again the
GameSpot account
I believe Jane Ryan Schubert I can't go
backwards at our favorite moment from
this episode and Nathan Shepard said
when meri invited mank Mike over for
Thanksgiving and then Jennifer said me
too I did and you're coming you're
coming over tomorrow and maybe a couple
others uh-huh my girlfriend omurice is
coming she's gonna make mashed potatoes
scalloped potatoes and I'm making a
turkey and when I mean making I mean
that my parents sent me a honey baked
turkey and I'm gonna put it in the oven
like it's literally precooked and it's
amazing and I can't [ __ ] it up and
that's my favorite kind of cook
I told you I bring something it'll
probably be all right I mean if you want
me bring food I can bring food bring
whatever you want I mean literally we
can eat pieces of Turkey and get drunk
you're fine
my Thanksgivings are quite chill I do
require alcohol Oh God oh I don't have
any ammo in this gun I [ __ ] up
oh shoot its butthole wait till it opens
it's gonna open okay Victor it's like Oh
God
normal let's think it says what so you
guys what
oh you're stuck here why didn't I give
me any ammo yeah that oh jeez oh jeez
shoot it yeah there you go
you sneaky son of a [ __ ]
and I think that's a shotgun yeah I'm
gonna need more ammo though remember our
last episode I was like running out of
ammo I'm gonna happen here if they don't
where's the but my friend Muhammad the
Gotti also said use a scanner everywhere
you go you are missing out on loads of
ammo
all right that's probably why I was like
running out of ammo
all right pretty much done here is it
gone I'll be in the clear there's no
[ __ ] way
son Goku said play Resident Evil 2 or 3
or 1 or code Veronica X anything works
welcome to Resident Evil
we have those seasons in our backlog go
for it go circuit look it up smart guy
all right so I'm gonna start using my
scan scan um and if I don't find some
ammo we're not gonna survive very so
that that will be flashing when there's
something nearby got it look at all this
mustard I found something I found it I
found something on the scanner 39% of
the machine
shoots weak spots like oh that head is
that Oh God Oh
Joop McDonald [ __ ] oh no balls so I
think it's that head of it or if that
bubble thing here's some butthole
inmates the heads here Oh cute idiot
yeah and you don't oh my god that's
impossible like juked I thought Oh balls
getting its little belly here yaaayyy ie
right near the seem to be do arm home
although that's naked hitting this
coming yeah that looks this thing
anything that's not those spikes [ __ ]
he's gonna run like I honestly don't
know how to dodge it do you know what I
was supposed to do forward and access
in a charge
move forward at the right time or do a
quick turn suck
it goes like I know I've been pushing
forward in X we're not doing anything
wrong a lot of people like Reddit boys
despite
I'm like out of ammo here got something
here the window and you know
recipe stay close up at you all run to
the club
I don't think there is
no wait [ __ ] I don't know
yeah but I'm like out of ammo again
yeah yeah
[Music]
here he comes
what happened
okay geez haha at least most the time
they like [ __ ] out a key and it's like
this is the key that we needed but in
this one it like like a ladder just
happens to fall how convenient
look I have zero ammo I think so I have
five bullets I can't take that because I
don't have a rifle I think you're full
on rifle ammo how I seem okay I'm gonna
scan this oh maybe you can now I can
take it oh wait do I have to equip it I
think it should just be a passive thing
copy nice should I take a rifle I could
switch to my rifle yeah I could replace
this gun you got what I only have three
slots right yeah what shotguns good for
stopping power yeah that way I can use
it was there anything else that I meant
let me just run over here real fast
it's my little scanning you why don't
you always teach me by saying that have
I done that before but it could be
anywhere cool alright I understand
I understand yes I've been I've been a
screw-up for quite some time now you've
been skating by on but like no wonder no
wonder you guys were like I was like
constant my [ __ ] dad wait he's got
upstairs okay let's go like no wonder I
was always like this game isn't getting
enough am i huh don't show oh look his
mother's hanging out here jack norman
prepared ships luxury liners purge
humanity Queen Zenobia organisms created
by the virus are milling around the
secret lab hunter type Bo W is infected
off-site will spread the virus off land
guys not very nice do my little scan
scan a little walk
oh yeah okay it's not a great day
Oh in the game
no just yeah yeah it's like gloomy you
know can i zoom in right stick we got a
lot more than we bargained for on this
ship I hope we can catch our breaths
after checking in with HQ is it this huh
it's not blinking an SP but light has to
be yellow and blinking it was blinking
it might be up above you hold on this
guy but like the ledge above II to the
left
oh yeah all right down below you
somewhere [ __ ]
alright [ __ ] this game this is one of
those things that in theory it's
satisfying to use but like Detective
Mode and Arkham the Arkham games like
you spend more time in that than out of
it right or rise a Tomb Raider
I'll check the antennas wiring
okay it's time for one of these little
thumbs see what we got here
looks like a rupee I think that should
do it
give it a shot Vermillion headquarters
do you read bunch idiot how do you know
boss looks like that someone crossed
this the BSAA logo it does look like
it's so homey just stay put I've got an
emergency call no wait director O'Brien
we've received an emergency call from
the ESF they've reported satellite
movement the European security force
[Music]
already in motion are we
looks like somebody's found the Queen
Zenobia sick
[Music]
comedy the Divine Comedy it's trying to
do stand-up
you all son of a [ __ ] HQ what's going
on all hell's about to break loose
the solar energy matrix s active what is
dashing at the Veltro hideouts on the
Mediterranean disguised his cruise ships
and satellites that destroy 10 igreja
right above us
they can't just ignore the ultimatum and
obliterate this ship
sorry
but I can't authorize that why-why-why
to the born song ah
Sasa thank God I got that new outfit of
a bag on the raincoat yeah
next
previously on resident evil revelations
no we're on the Queen Semiramis
don't have a signal maybe we can fix it
[Music]
we did it should be defined here [ __ ]
real hard [ __ ] everywhere
sorry
but I can't authorize so dramati are you
guys all working on Friday no I don't
think so how's this episode gonna get up
oh we have the UK is working okay thanks
charnae team yeah
the UK does not have a holiday that's
right they do not have Thanksgiving
sir what is going on actually that
reminds me I gotta message someone right
now is impossible Chris is traveling by
sea looks like you guys were just dead
in the water anyway well like what's
what am I supposed to do like what's our
plan
did he just signed us to our death like
did you just like send us a death
warrant here cuz like it's just weird
like he's literally giving us no option
he just said he was gonna delay stuff
but like you tell us like what to do yes
first jackass without the plan
there's a little light going on oh there
it is
I'm sure you've already scanned this
room I know but look at the light I'm no
light experts oh wait no I think you
missed that earlier maybe it's a prop
Jen maybe like every once in a while it
just pops one in there oh how did I miss
that
Oh
um well I can't that door oh right that
other door I think you're so smart do
you woods an elevator mm-hmm favorite
kind of doors those are nice
every time
stuffed thanks Parker genius so good
always there the UAV what is it doing on
this ship okay that's kind of wait go
back to that that's a foreboding King
thing to have on a ship ship wreck wait
why is the music scary Oh balls that's
really far away before deck listen for
Skinner you're making a lot of
assumptions about me and ships okay so I
need to go to either the top or the
bottom
good down a floor first I can't the
elevator stopped remember they told airs
right behind you
you were there when we learned about the
elevator and I was there and I saw the
stairs right now I feel about this
attitude wait no oh ho not now on posit
suicide drive that's not helpful why do
they do that
wrap it up like I'm still in this giant
circle I just go to the side that
doesn't have the weapon crate I can't no
no I mean like in out of the map like
find the weapon crank or the opposite or
there's a weapon upgrade crate on one
side of the Grand Hall go to the door on
the opposite side that it's not no no no
no come out I understand
listen to me small okay go that way
okay don't I understand what you're
trying to you're going to the opposite
side go to the door over there that one
yes on this floor
yes
who the [ __ ] yourself no not that one
who's talking who is that
I do what I can here I don't know
it should be the four-day hey still
can't talk it's Raymond how does he know
what we're trying to do
[ __ ] these doors is too slow
oh my god let me yeah this is right wait
it depends on if you want to take this
floor or the other oh my god did he save
me oh all right and then he farted oh
you can't scan him through Scanlan can't
scan them I love my own joke that was my
joke no but I said it first what you say
first I finished the joke first what was
the joke can't stand all right we can't
stand yeah all right so hopefully no I
think that's the stairs that's caved in
I think you do need to go up I need to
go up okay okay wait dude full
disclosure I could be completely wrong
but if my are you [ __ ]
nice to know ya oh [ __ ]
see that's that ball of goo it respawns
[ __ ]
oh yeah just keep going so I don't want
to fight it but I don't know how god he
knows how do you stairs I just poop my
pants a little okay so let's just run
well hold on if you're in a room where
there's no skins room if there appears
to be a red substance
okay well the noise the sound effect
alright there's no need for that also
says the person who perfect I made that
if I made that noise I wouldn't never
hear the end of it okay you're right
that's you're right
oh it's her that's her yeah she sure is
yeah unless you want a trophy ups I'm
sorry oh please my account killer get a
trophy for you I was kidding
I use deal you're bleeding hello knock
knock who's there
pull it pull it who bullet I hardly know
it all right so I need to take a left on
this hallway okay oh my god I [ __ ]
confused myself is this right yeah it's
so this map is butts
I'm really glad I'm gonna use those
rightful oh I'm up oh oh it's her again
how did she get here
go keep going around not this door not
this door are you sure yes go to your
right and then that door
that map could be better
and then just take a look right at the
end the hallway no you don't you got it
the mini-map up top right I do yeah
just follow that hallway to the right
and then oh yeah there's a mini-map yeah
it's a mini but now you'll actually
mini-map okay so I want to go don't know
maybe they want you go to the stereo you
can oh wait Han okay
stop let me get a good lay of the land
here yes
you're going down straight no you're
going straight but I want to go down see
how I can I don't know that because I
think the stairs are caved in I think
you want to go over but I oh I might
want to go up and then over that down is
it here it looks like a why else would
they put
are you [ __ ] kidding me get up [ __ ]
I'm gonna die
I [ __ ] absolute trash balls where in
the shoulder
shamil jaws oh shoot his tongue Parker's
got it once you can't what the [ __ ] was
that why is it hangout its knowledge
just shoot it all right today not okay
dude getting sick of that thing was
annoying rage I guess yeah I mean I
think I like remember this was caved in
at the bottom we want to go well look I
rotate that you keep rotating and then
when you have the good angle you just
shoot back away I don't know what you
mean yeah you got to go up so bridge
yeah
which sounds higher to me than lower
cabins you know that's gonna be down
here I know that [ __ ] is gonna be down
here
they're up here I guess
yeah I think you're on the right way
there's only one way out oh yeah you go
the stairs on the bridge name down
you know this [ __ ] is here she's ugly
she's big pain in my ass man here we go
[Music]
scary these is this orchestral tension
also I'm like out of health
communications they're down all right so
I need to go to the other side and go
down I think just right it's truly the
mystery of our time all right so I'm
down here and I am looking for what make
where's this where's this blue light
[ __ ] this map blows but I want to go
down take a left at beyond the hallway
and then
or way what the [ __ ] texture that no
it's either this one or it's one of the
two doors in the south side it might be
this one
I might've [ __ ] up games room though I
think I [ __ ] that yeah yeah but scan
this room
it's ready to ship and riprap Resident
Evil 7 he's dead alright I just made a
mistake alright so we're going back and
I'm looking for the elevator the
elevator stairs yeah it's an elevator
and where am I taking this down I don't
know which one sounds lower try your
deck promenade is always like a loft so
death are you sure yep oh yeah I mean a
deck is gonna be below a problem I don't
know if that's the one you want though I
want to go down they're both down I'm
just saying
Dacus downer check
I'm just gonna check my mouth oh I'm
[ __ ] there good job well that's like
a resonable to call back with a licorice
crown over the window it's in a box of
course that box had three ammo
I could really use some help I have zero
healthy's Cultra find like one health
that would be really happy
helpful helpful nice so this is my check
it right first liquors hunters
shop ain't can I check it right fine
Battletoads oh I see another one right
up his people that's their weak spot
I wasn't able to scan them due to the
fact that they like straight up
disappear all right well I'm just gonna
follow him I assume he knows what's best
here well hello
good thing he's paying
Chris protect me with your life Parker
whatever Oh balls I miss thank you
[Music]
oh it's in there wait before you trigger
that okay nice boxes too when you get
the chance
oh did he throw their here I did no I
think that's Parker shut up no you a
hoppy [ __ ]
carotids no oh god don't worry I got it
over here thank God if you assemble it
name's Clyde Clyde looks like Christmas
ornament he looks like a bust of a real
person he looks like he's made out of
molten wood what your two copper
nice
so that was like an hour we can keep
going a little longer
did she put the whole thing together
well he just watched we need this
launched as far as possible thanks that
was lucky she looks good to me
quit we're good to go okay
oh she doesn't call him jackass she
calls him by his name can I open these
oh my god they did that whole fight
without doing this oh my god
classic married
where did he go
yes you're controlling her from the
bridge it's been like a [ __ ] forever
hallway how long this hallway is he's
been walking down after like 20 minutes
it's not a throwback to the fact I've
been scanning hands so dramatic the
later we should have activated the laser
okay so oh my god is this attainment can
I not grab this okay great
whoa that's creepy whose rifles good
offense apart yes
I didn't mean to do that you kill you
kill two people you went through him and
hit the barrel just as I tonight
backward gainer Steve gainer can you
like [ __ ] right off thank you no they
like become a mannequin before they die
I really don't have time for this
what's wrong the renkel I don't know I
just thought I'd mix it up just a quick
scan here
she can't even reload while she's
bug eat [ __ ] Barker explode
geez going my partner is gonna be fun
okay I got seven he's not even holding
the shotgun by the pump oh you're not
look do you not know how time works I
got two minutes and 45 seconds turns
apart she turns the camera says time as
a flood there's nothing there's no time
to talk about time there's not enough
time this is a long elevator ride maybe
that's what she meant this is like a two
and a half minute elevator ride yeah all
right so can you guide me guess you
gotta go down there okay good job thank
you Oh Walt let me out
yeah okay okay there's that ladder on
the other side okay I think I need to
heal again
oh that's are you [ __ ] kidding oh my
Falls
yeah just keep moving right now I don't
think I don't know if you kill Rachel
here or not I don't want to like she's
stupid unbelievable the door animation
save you or the knife I don't know okay
so I need to go all the way the other
side yeah I got this
Yuki's act opposite way that we chose
that's it all right where am I going
through this door no no no no yeah right
wait for for traps yeah
you're going that way but where's now
left
oh no just keep going keep going our PG
there you should get that check out that
I really yeah I just
he took one for the team
yeah okay now go I only have 50 seconds
do I need this right now
I feel like I should not god bless you
[ __ ] like give me a [ __ ] second okay
head away all sure anticlimactic yeah
yeah
Haven one arm here slower than the other
it pisses me the [ __ ] off badge it looks
weird
looks like a toddler in a human's face
[Laughter]
ciao
why did it just deploy chap what was he
trying to shoot it down
how'd his eyes are too close together it
looks like Santa if you were on the
cover of GQ
the chaff is gonna stop the lead
does she ever have an expression
yeah
Oh
my god I've seen a perfect storm
well then
let's do another one all right let me
run to the bathroom really good sorry
oh my goodness sauce oh I can't believe
it
hope you guys have enjoyed these
episodes so far I hope you have a good
Thanksgiving
what should Mike's name be
I'm really bad with alliteration
especially on the spot
mashed sounds like my Hardy right mashed
potatoes my hearty that's pretty good
right
oh no I'm not smart I feel like I did my
best this is my mic does those um cuz
they're both M's
you get turkey and stuffing mashed
potatoes gravy cranberry sauce green
bean casserole that's it right pumpkin
pie apple pie I've made my choice
yeah I think just gonna have a nice
little tiny turkey Thanksgiving tomorrow
which would be nice and then before you
know it it's December and then it's
Christmastime just gonna be crazy
so much that needs to be done
so stupid you know everyone does
Christmas cards and I never do it
because I'm terrible with addresses but
this year I started address list and I'm
gonna write Christmas cards to my family
and it's gonna have a little photo just
like all those people do like normal
people do I guess and it's gonna be like
look how cool this was fridge photos I
think I what you're supposed to do now
for the love of God marry quick turn
quick turn I'm sorry Michael Pete I'm
gonna practice my quick turn I'm gonna
do it right now that was nice
the time is come right O'Brien like I
look like Santa's dick what do you know
it's Santa's dick looks like don't ask
why some of you on answers Justice
beltro makes me laugh because it sounds
like velcro didn't like us can exist
thanks to groups like that
so where do Chapter eight
I don't know yes all on the line which
is a really good pun for whoa are they
working together yeah that's why he's
want to call them earlier oh I see I
thought he was helping them to me this
photo says a lot which is like I'm evil
and the other guys like I'm just trying
to do my job the situation loose lips
sink ships
a bigger line where they say about loose
lips and I want to show you that blown
up by a missile
my cleavage
[Laughter]
no it's so funny sure to scan this
around
[ __ ] I shouldn't scan your deck I should
have used that time to escape
hey wait how do I swim fast I don't this
is yours your one speed really yeah I
don't think you could open doors
underwater like that pushing push but
you'd have no force yeah
let's give
oh I see I see there's like a little
puzzle here it will underwater puzzle I
don't know how to
he's helping so much oh my god that
guy's gonna float here cuz you need to
be on this side
oh I thought that's where you were
listen those who are symbolic for us in
many ways kind of thank me maybe yeah
alright I'll do some research what's the
plan
I don't know I'm Parker I'm just gonna
flow here while you figure out yeah I
guess you can go up do I want to go up
seems really get away from the water I
want to go where the walk RA I would
assume off the elevator shaft give
another RPG I see they didn't bother to
update the weapon resolution from the
3ds
[Music]
[Music]
Wow Wow
[Music]
that's good
yep
this elevator okay
let's go peace away
with that see on my map it's yellow do
you see it where no just go through the
story I think it's in here
we're gonna box stick I think what Sam
what's the way you go back down to the
first floor I don't know what they want
I guess it's back down to that yellow
thing but
really
isn't that where I came from no you came
up this ladder I think they want you to
go to the other side of that yeah down
that ladder oh I see I see cuz it was
blocked down there okay I understand I
got confused where all those little
water vaginas that we fought earlier I
know
there's bullets under here
[Music]
underwater scenes give me great anxiety
a trident
fornix I won't even get that weapon
upgrade now that the waters high so I'm
going down
is this like Tomb Raider Tomb Raider did
this all technically this did it before
- I know we're both in agreement wait
which one came first listen carefully
she didn't like it now the ship is done
for it why was it red but we can see the
oceans the environment it's in danger
night that I can't it's too dented
oh no it's one of those vaginas what do
I do
I feel like that shouldn't kill me
really yeah follow the man
isn't that right nope I don't even know
where I am
air above you right there oh [ __ ] where
do I see it it's a lot of holding your
breath in this dude this you took me the
wrong way you butthole why would there
be an air thing no wait don't go yet
dude you might be right I'm just saying
you have area there's no timer you have
all the time just say no I think this is
the room with that weapon operate on top
of the tank oh yeah shotgun shells now
what the [ __ ] yeah whatever eat it right
all right I'm leaving all right so I
want to go up the stairs here yeah throw
me off that the red doors can be open
now yeah it's oh there's the weapon
upgrade no I need air and lower I need
air we that's what we should be talking
about there's no error yeah there's
where
it's really head-butting the ceiling
it's really hard to control her to your
left and then now nope that glass oh
[ __ ]
your directions oh yeah they're bigger
yeah get out there [ __ ] hey I like how
he waits for me to breathe first and
he's like he's a gentleman Hilde like
die if I don't breathe
oh my god go down I'm gonna kill you
vaginas where am I going
well stop looking at your I'm not
looking but guide me before I die I
think you want to go up those there we
go that's the one else think about
that's when he came from casino it's
either I tried this on the door in this
room here there is another door
I need your Minnie Mouse no not that one
dude something just staring at it
I should probably breathe one more time
okay so this follow this to the end up
the stairs get you there whatever it is
there for twenty use hard so up here
there's a hole here so I want to go
through that home oh no I guess you're
right yeah there the are these if I can
you even go through these men's I don't
[ __ ] know
yeah I guess
I
guess
my dad is this I got a little yellow dot
in here
yeah maybe go out and then down Jeremy
yeah maybe through that door and then
you gotta go above you okay I'm gonna
breathe over to him sauce
not what like I would call fun
[Music]
there was a guy in a board meeting that
pushed really hard for underwater
swimming levels it's just not my thing
well they're just reusing all
environments with water I don't know how
hard that is and vagina but the yellow
dot is in that other room like I'm going
back here's the thing I think that no I
need to tried it he what's the yellow
dot mean that's where you're going but
it's on a different floor oh I see okay
I'm sorry I need to breathe oh [ __ ] I
need to breathe oh [ __ ] Eddie breathe I
don't have time for this
oh god I'm gonna die I think you just
going straight up
I'm trying oh this is just like watching
the Titanic you know he's like hold your
breath right when the ship village goes
down he's like my name is Chris stop
calling me Roger
up and then okay does that mean this one
again yeah damn you've gone through
these pipes so many [ __ ] I know this
game is like twelve thousand square feet
and everything else like just reusable
footage if there's one of those balls in
here
remember the balls that are stuck on the
walls and then they turn into these
men's yes have some respect
I wish I could use my [ __ ] gun
get up there [ __ ] Gary
well going up is always a good thing
Oh lectures down fire rate three from
the shotgun bind one I must have a fire
rate three on it no I think you just
need to fire it doesn't it look like it
doesn't it is weird maybe under Hannibal
okay have I already read this yes the
old stenchy bods he's like I just got to
play one more hand before this place
goes under
they'll throw mr. party
his name is Veltro yes um you want to
end it there okay next time sure
something it's five-run chapter 9 out of
12 we're closed
we're killing it maybe one more today or
one episode like one more episode before
we're done that's yeah probably because
I'm burning through these episodes yeah
pretty fun so again happy Thanksgiving
weekend well belated Thanksgiving to
people in the u.s. yeah you just want to
bring that up again don't you uh for
those of you who might not know at this
point I'm Mike that's what you did when
I went to the bathroom that's good yeah
and then everybody outside of the u.s. a
happy weekend anyway have a good rest of
it we'll be back next week as always on
Saturday usually around 3 p.m. Pacific
with resident Knievel we're almost to
the end of Revelation but thanks so much
for joining us absolutely I'm in the
kitchen this is Mike mashed potatoes
Marty wishing you a Happy Thanksgiving
we will see you again next week in the
comments Nathan Shepard always post you
can evil discord oh so use that so yeah
potatoes Marty